foreign
[Music]
this is uh framework Friday special
guest Andrew Wilkinson joining Andrew I
wanted to hear from you because I think
you like Frameworks just as much as I do
is there a framework that you've been
using or uh has like stood out to you as
particularly useful lately it's actually
a quote
um and it's easy choices hard life hard
choices Easy Life by this guy Jersey
Greg Rick I think Tim Ferriss uh
famously shared this quote years ago and
it always sticks with me and it most
recently uh has been on my mind and it's
it's one of those things where
um you will often find a situation where
you know what the right thing to do is
so let's say an employee is you know
just not working out or there's a
difficult decision that needs to be made
and naturally the thing to do is to
delay it or to try and make it work and
I have really shifted over the last two
years of really trying to make the hard
choice and I found that it always
results in an easier life
um that the road that the road to hell
is paved with good intentions and that
when I try and make it work with someone
or I try and make a business work it
just never does so for me you know the
and the other piece of that framework is
if if I ever think should I fire this
person that means I absolutely should
because you never think about a
superstar and go should I fire them you
go oh my God I'd be lost without them so
if you have that thought you got to
immediately fire that person make a hard
decision and that applies to so many
different parts of business
I like that I'll give one one uh
personal experience caveat with that
recently in the past two years there's
been a couple people that we were like
should we fire this person and I had the
same mentality as you like once the
question comes up you know it's obvious
right this sort of like if it's not a
hell yes it's a no type of approach to
people on your team especially on a
small team but the one caveat was have I
given this person Clarity on what their
role is and what's expected what winning
looks like and what I found was that in
a couple circumstances I didn't give
them a clear role and I didn't give them
Clarity on what I needed what was
winning in this role
and once we did that we said okay before
we just you know cut the cord I'm going
to do this one thing and I'll know
within two weeks three weeks from that
from this point on if that was correct
and that actually turned somebody who
was we were about to fire them into
basically like a star driver in in like
that function of the company and so
that's my only caveat with that one but
I'll also add
um one of the like takeaways from the
easy choices hard life hard choices Easy
Life thing is when you think two options
when you're trying to weigh a decision
should I do a or b and you're trying to
weigh A or B A or B you can't just you
just literally you can't decide
you should just simply say which one is
harder because your brain is naturally
discounting the uh the hard one and and
making it seem like oh these are about
equal because the difficulty is
something that you're taking into
consideration
um and your brain wants to avoid
difficulty it wants to avoid the
short-term pain or struggle that might
come so what looks to be equal to equal
choices are not actually equal at all
the um the one that's that's harder is
actually a much better choice and your
brain is just trying to sandbag it weigh
it down because it wants to avoid that
that struggle so that's another useful
one because I had a situation recently
Where I Was A or B A or B I just
couldn't decide for the life of me and
then
um I went down this Rabbit Hole of like
how do you make a tough decision because
I was like normally I'm very very
decisive normally it's pretty easy this
one was so difficult and when I went
down this Rabbit Hole like okay what is
the world's philosophy on this that was
one that really helped me which was your
brain is not accurately pricing the two
decisions decisions correctly it puts a
huge tax on the one that's difficult and
that's why it seems equal but that tax
is not real it's just the brain trying
to like you know punish you for
short-term pain
I can find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out-of-sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
I love that and that exactly it's
pushing through and doing the hard thing
and there's been so many times where
Chris and I you know let's say that
we're doing a hire and we've been doing
the hiring process for six months and we
haven't found the candidate and we have
someone that we think is like a b or a c
but we're exhausted at the end of it the
right thing to do is to actually
continue the process and do the hard
thing and do more phone calls and stuff
but it's so easy to get fatigued and
choose the wrong person and every time I
do that it's always a colossal failure
um so I'm really trying to lean into
that
um
the other one that I've been finding
really interesting lately
um so there's this great quote by Upton
Sinclair never expect a man to
understand something that is paycheck
depends on him not understanding so
effectively
um let's say you go to someone and you
say
hey
um you know this business model is
terrible uh you shouldn't do it it's
doomed in five years but if they're
making a ton of money doing it and it
rewards them it will be very difficult
cognitively for them to face that
painful truth and this can apply to
anything effectively it's people will
not do things that are that don't
benefit them or they're not incentivized
to do in some way so here's an example
so we own a whole bunch of different
agencies and the logical thing when you
own all these agencies is to say hey big
agency you should refer your smaller
leads to the smaller agency and so um
you know we kind of introduced everyone
and we're not going to force them to but
we figured you know they would get it
they're like oh they're part of the
family we'll refer the leads over here
and I just did a call with one of the
smaller agency guys and he's like man
I'm not getting any leads what's going
on and I realize that for these guys
there's no reason to do it right they
might get a little referral healthy or
something that we've structured but it
actually will not make a difference
their bonus and on the downside if they
refer the work they could lose the
person that might come back to them for
future work or if it goes badly that
person might email them and say hey I
can't believe you referred that me to
this agency they sucked or whatever it
is and so I've just realized time and
time again people will not do what
they're incentivized to not do yeah the
the thing you said uh at the beginning
is sort of like the innovator's Dilemma
too right it's like
um a company that's success depends on
the world being a certain way is going
to have a huge blind spot to the change
in that that scenario and this is like
why for the innovators dilemma it's like
you would assume that the big company
whose domain expertise is in this area
they'll be the ones to invent that
future and it's almost never them that
invents that future it's some upstart
who sees the world a little differently
and says oh yeah all that stuff that's
the old way yeah screw that we're gonna
do it this new way and the you know the
big companies like sort of like screw
that what do you mean how how could you
screw that that's that's the way the
world is and so you can sort of and then
you can can you use that to your benefit
so like for you for example what would
be your blind spots like basically what
would you not see because your paycheck
depends on it won't be a certain way and
I I've been thinking about this a lot
right you look at Dolly and you go okay
in five years will you be able to type
into Dolly build me away website that
looks like this and then it comes back
and you say oh more creative or make the
logo bigger or do this will Design still
be a thing right and I've always been
rewarded by not overestimating these
things in the near term and just
Trucking on but I've been thinking about
that I think about some of our other
businesses now that can be disrupted and
I don't want to over index on that but I
always try and remember that I have this
crazy perverse cognitive bias where you
know what is the great quote it's like
all forecasts are based on the past
right or all all your knowledge is based
on the past you don't know what's coming
and I don't think that someone who owned
I'm reading like a great
book about
um news the newspaper industry right now
and all the guys that own newspapers in
1998 like they all thought oh we're good
Forever This is the the best possible
business we have a monopoly it's okay to
pay 20 times earnings to buy a paper and
you know look how that turned out you
could not have predicted Craigslist
classified disruption Etc and so yeah
people are just incapable of seeing
these things in themselves
yeah that's a great Point uh that's a
great point I think it's also true with
Investments if you
um like if you're invested in something
you know when new information comes to
light you sort of have to recalculate
from scratch
do would I if I didn't have this
investment today would I invest the same
amount of money in the thing and people
would be surprised how often the answer
is no
um that you would not put that same
amount of investment in this thing and
it happens even at a small scale with
like employee stock options or whatever
it's like you get stock options or rsus
in a company you you earn them and not
like you know 50 of your stock portfolio
is in this one company and I'm like you
probably wouldn't have if you just I
just gave you that amount of money you
wouldn't put 50 of this company but
you'll leave it there right because
inertia right like you know it's it is
it is that way so let's let it continue
to be that way and so I think one of the
best things you could do is train your
brain like train yourself to get rid of
some of these biases and blind spots and
just know that by default they're there
you're not special you're not going to
just not have them you're going to have
them unless you proactively fight
against the gravity to um to like sort
of rid yourself of them so you don't
make the same mistakes everybody else
does
so um there's two really amazing things
that people should go and study if you
want to I spent a couple years actually
just reading and rereading books on
psychology to try and Hammer this stuff
into my brain my favorite book on it is
influenced by Robert cialdini it's
amazing it just kind of goes through all
of the kind of thinking traps we get
into
um and you know it's anchor bias
um and you know
comparison and you know all these all
these kind of ways that you trick
yourself and then the other great one is
the psychology of human misjudgment by
Charlie Munger which is a speech he gave
at Harvard if you just Google it on
YouTube
um you'll find it there and just I
listened to that in the car over and
over and over again and now I see it
everywhere
totally all right this is great uh
thanks for joining the framework Fridays
and uh yeah if you if you like this
tweet at uh Andrew and uh tweet at me
Andrew your handle is what a Wilkinson
on Twitter yeah a Wilkinson cool and I'm
Sean VP on Twitter all right see ya
[Music]